Thank God It's Friday and that means
it's time for Friday Follies and for
that we turn to Raymond Arroyo Fox News
contributor
and uh person extraordinaire all right
Raymond Biden had a speech in New Mexico
I didn't get to see it I was so upset
but I know you might have seen part of
it look at one point he froze during
this address likely because the staff
told him not to say his son died in Iraq
which he has said repeatedly but there
were other stumbles too
my son Beau was one of those parishes he
went the fittest guy in his unit and
came home and
we came home but died of glioblastoma
and represented Mark
to decay
excuse me takeno
and I signed the pen
[Music]
poor man Laura he really at this point
they should have a staff member with a
neon flag to show him where to exit he
just he never knows where to go
no but Raymond how many times has this
happened this is like a drinking game at
this point when Biden goes in the wrong
direction take a shot of you know Casa
Amigos I mean honestly don't do that
you'll never get up you'll never wake
again and look if you think Kamala could
up Biden's game let's check in on her
gun violence speech in Chicago today
okay so this is where you're gonna hear
the geek in me I love Venn diagrams so
those three circles sometimes there's
more I've asked my team to prepare a
Venn diagram on from where are we seeing
the attacks it's so funny lower third
Laura I mean but for Venn diagrams what
would she talk about she just repeats
that here's something she could run
through a very big Venn diagram we've
been reporting on lizzo Whose dancers
are charging her with sexual harassment
and abuse well tonight there are reports
that the NFL has dropped lizzo from
consideration for the Super Bowl
halftime show due to those allegations
you see it doesn't pay to be nasty so
we'll see what happens oh look Laura
look what I have
oh the lamp Okay I'm granting you three
wishes what are they oh I'm so happy
first Laura in Oakland California
burglaries are up 41 from last year
assaults have doubled since 2019. I wish
the cops in Oakland could offer their
ravaged citizens Better Home Security
Options than this
Oakland Police recommended steel braces
for residential doors and air horns the
idea is if you set it off your neighbor
would hear it set theirs off and more
people are alert that there's danger
their next recommendations will be
harmonicas and jingle bells Laura I mean
this is ridic maybe they could put
together a whole chorus in the backyard
but it's not going to stop crime this is
no I don't it is a little bit
disconcerting for the criminal though
and it I think you should have a
different way the speaker the voice over
the speaker from the security system
should say
how was your week I mean let's just
engage the criminal at this point that's
what we should do make it make it a more
hospitable environment to commit crimes
all right Raymond what's your next
question
well my next one is Porsche unveiled a
new ad this week partially shot in
Lisbon I wish people would just leave
statues alone even if you were removing
them digitally this was the first
version of the porschead you'll notice
there's a landmark curiously missing
then after they received complaints
Porsche reposted the ad and guess what
like a miracle Jesus reappeared you'd
think people who were spending a hundred
thousand dollars on a vehicle I think
they can tolerate a statue of Jesus in
the background of that ad just saying
it's you know it's my favorite car so
I'm not commenting on it but I don't
like that at all but I do love my
position all right um what else Laura
final wish if you're trying to convince
voters that you're a truth teller I wish
candidates would not undermine their
credibility by not doing what they claim
to be doing this is how not to pump gas
in your campaign ad
remember two dollar a gallon gas I do
and then Joe Biden became president of
the United States and launched his war
on energy we just unveiled the Pence
energy plan that will not only put our
country back on a path to energy
Independence but by 2040 we will reclaim
America's role as the leading producer
of energy in the world
no when you pull the when you pull the
nozzle off the pump it beeps at you and
that's what you hear throughout the ad
the other thing is anybody who pumps
their own gases I do the moment you
start pumping the gas Maria menudo shows
up and starts yelling entertainment uh
headlines at you so that's how you know
the gas is being pumped you hear Maria
or some news or weather headline you get
none of that with pens hey come on don't
tell us I hate all of those video
messages Sam just said that she noticed
he didn't even squeeze the handle he
like you
all of us were talking about this the
other day what the consultants and the
ad people get paid in these campaigns
frankly is Criminal there's not a good
ad out there and these people get just
millions of dollars for doing these
stupid ads that's a who who allowed him
to do that ad all right Raymond you got
your three wishes behind them now so
long no have a great weekend hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else